on ne pourra plus désespérer billancourt
la régie renault autorisés à fermer son
usine parisienne tchécoslovaquie le
parti communiste sur le point de perdre
le monopole du pouvoir
contact officiel entre gouvernement et
l'opposition nouvelle manifestation
monstre ce soir à prague et ya lors
d'incidents au pays basque espagnol
après l'attentât de madrid contre des
députés nationalistes basques l'attentât
a été revendiqué par légal
comment empêcher le recours excessif au
travail intérimaire et aux contrats à
durée déterminée
un projet de loi en avant première même
monsieur bonsoir ils sont à nouveau dans
la rue ils sont plus de 200 milles ce
soir encore à prague à réclamer la
liberté et la démission du chef du parti
communiste le régime qui hier soir
encore rejeter en bloc les critiques à
son encontre et bien le régime est en
train de plier sous la pression
populaire des contacts officiels ont eu
lieu aujourd'hui entre le premier
ministre et des représentants des
mouvements d'opposition
après la pologne la hongrie et
l'allemagne de l'est
le communisme rengorge en
tchécoslovaquie martine laroche-joubert
cinq jours de manifestations
ininterrompues cinq jours pour réveiller
une choco slovaquie engourdi depuis 20
ans l'état celle les violences
policières de la semaine dernière qui
ont poussé dans la rue tous ceux qui n'y
croyaient plus l'indignation a décuplé
leur combativité endormi depuis vendredi
chaque jour ils déposent des bougies sur
le lieu des affrontements
aujourd'hui encore ils sont près de 200
milles à défiler avec banderoles et
slogans ya quelques le chef du parti
communiste dehors vive la liberté des
droits de l'homme à bas la violence une
pugnacité qui donne ses premiers
résultats avec la rencontre aujourd'hui
entre le gouvernement et une délégation
de l'opposition
la mort ce dialogue souligné par
l'ancien ministre les affaires
étrangères du printemps de prague
aujourd'hui pour la première fois les
gens de la rue et
jean voir ce rongeur c'est très
important ce soir les manifestations
continuent mais la police n'intervient
pas ce sont les ordres du premier
ministre adamek qui dans les coulisses
ou mons de la rumeur de la rue
remportera peut-être la bataille des
plans pour le pouvoir
et depuis quelques minutes maintenant en
propre la manifestation vient de se
disperser dans le calme
la situation n'est pas bloquée il faut
que régime trouve la voie du dialogue
avec la société civile
c'est ce qu'a déclaré ce soit alexandre
do check à une radio italienne pour
l'ancien des gens du printemps de prague
le problème est avant tout politique
tout comme en 68 on s'y attendait depuis
quelques temps mail annonce signifie
malgré tout la fin d'une époque et même
d'un mythe billancourt va fermer la
régie renault a reçu aujourd'hui l'aval
du premier ministre pour fermer son
usine qui a été longtemps le symbole est
la place forte de la conscience ouvrière
en france maryse mano angers motte
les ateliers de l'île seguin filmée par
une caméra cachée depuis quatre ans
l'usiné est interdite aux journalistes
les 4000 ouvriers qui travaillent ici
savent que la régie projette de fermer
l'usiné sur ses chaînes modernisé il ya
cinq ans sortent 420 véhicules par jour
des express et quelques airs 5
la production pourrait facilement
tripler mais la régie ne le veut pas
impuissants les ouvriers on veut fermer
l'atelier des r4 regarder cette chaîne
et vides abandonnées
il est aujourd'hui que cet abandon
progressif de l'activité va s'accélérer
jusqu'à la fermeture totale en 1992
lusine de billancourt implanté sur une
île sur cinq niveaux en plein coeur de
l'agglomération parisienne avec les
problèmes d'approvisionnement et
d'environnement que cela pose ne peut
malgré les efforts de son personnel à
tous les niveaux arrivé à un niveau de
performance suffisant
la fermeture de billancourt c'est la fin
d'un mythe celui des premiers grands
succès de l'automobile avec laquelle
chevaux la dauphine et la 4l
celui de la forteresse ouvrière et de la
toute puissance de la cgt avec les
grandes grèves de 1947 et de mai 68
celui enfin de la vitrine sociale
renault innove en accordant par exemple
la troisième semaine de congés payés
un héritage que la cgt veut aujourd'hui
défendre en s'opposant à la fermeture
si l'on ferme ce site de billancourt
l'industrie automobile française
disposera d'une usine de moins pour
répondre aux besoins à la fois du marché
français mais du marché international
pour la régie billancourt et
technologiquement dépassé mais la vendée
11 hectares de l'île seguin et des
terrains alentour constituera une
formidable opération immobilière et
financière
sa fermeture est aussi un argument face
aux autorités de bruxelles qui réclament
une réduction des capacités de
production un échange des 12 milliards
dead que renault a reçu du gouvernement
le projet de loi doit être présenté dans
une semaine en conseil des ministres
mais déjà les chefs d'entreprise grogne
si le projet soit 100 est adoptée ils ne
pourront plus recourir à l'envi au
travail intérimaire et aux contrats à
durée déterminée qui représente en ce
moment plus d'une embauche sur deux les
grandes lignes du projet avec gérard le
caire les entreprises ne pourront
recourir à des emplois intérimaires ou
des contrats à durée déterminée que dans
trois cas le remplacement d'un salarié
absent
l'accroissement temporaire de l'activité
de l'entreprise
enfin pour les emplois à caractère
saisonnier dans tous les cas le contrat
de travail sera renouvelable une fois
mais la durée totale ne pourra excéder
12 mois un établissement ayant procédé à
un licenciement économique devra
attendre six mois pour recruter un
intérim ou un cdd ayant la même
qualification en cas d'infraction des
sanctions sont prévues actuellement plus
d'une embauche sur deux se fait en
contrat à durée déterminée ou en intérim
le gouvernement entend supprimer
certains abus mais le patronat
critiquent un projet qui risque selon
lui de casser la dynamique de l'emploi
la grogne et la ron dans l'enseignement
supérieur les personnels non enseignants
et des étudiants ont protesté séparément
aujourd'hui tout en négociant avec le
ministère de tutelle
chantal kiberlain serge me serais on les
appelle les oubliés de l'éducation les
personnels administratifs ils étaient ce
matin dans la rue est familles venues de
toute la france pour clamer leur
ras-le-bol et réclamer des emplois et
des salaires décents à moins de 6000
francs nets par mois
notre épicier ne nous recevra plus il
s'agit véritablement d'une notion de
salaire minimum de l'indécence de payer
ses fonctionnaires en même temps des
négociations se déroulaient au ministère
négociations qui ont abouti à la
création de 500 emplois des 90 des
indemnités supplémentaires et la mise en
place d'une politique de recrutement des
avancées reconnu par la scène qui
cependant reste réservé les inquiétudes
demeurent et la principale des
inquiétudes que j'ai rappelé fermement
au ministre c'est la négociation au
niveau de la fonction publique
beaucoup des problèmes des
fonctionnaires de l'éducation nationale
dépendent de l'issue de cette
négociation sur la refonte de la grille
14h30 c'est le tour des étudiants de
manifester leur mauvaise humeur les
raisons pour l'essentiel dans près de la
moitié des universités le nombre des
étudiants est deux fois supérieure aux
possibilités d'accueil
une délégation a été reçue par le
ministre lionel jospin a confirmé son
intention d'accélérer les constructions
universitaires mais on peut se demander
s'il suffira d'une promesse pour calmer
la grogne des étudiants
violente offensive de la guérilla
aujourd'hui au salvador où les combats
ont repris la guérilla investi le
quartier résidentiel de la capitale et
en particulier l'hôtel sheraton 29
personnes dont quatre américains des
membres de l'ambassade sont entre ses
mains le département d'état à washington
vient de le confirmer
jean marc qui moussent les guérilleros
le fmln s'étaient retirés des quartiers
populaires vol à trente six heures ils
se sont emparés depuis ce matin d'une
partie de l'hôtel sheraton en plein
coeur du quartier le plus riche de san
salvador le quartier des ambassades
schubert par le feu de leurs véhicules
blindés
les troupes gouvernementales qui
tiennent l'autre partie de l'hôtel tente
un encerclement oui mais pas question de
régler le problème au canon lourd six ou
sept étrangers sont actuellement aux
mains des guérilleros à l'intérieur de
l'hôtel
parmi eux quatre américains des
conseillers militaires affirment la
guérilla washington confirme seulement
qu'il s'agit de fonctionnaires
probablement des membres d'ambassades
américaines
les américains disposent de salvador de
50 militaires chargés de conseiller
l'armée salvadorienne
ils n'ont pas le droit par décision du
congrès de participer au combat pour
l'instant alors que les tirs continuent
personne ne prononce encore le mot otage
mais désormais les guérilleros
communistes du fmln dispose d'un nouveau
moyen de pression sur le principal allié
de leur ennemi le gouvernement
salvadorien les états unis et la maison
blanche sans autre précision enfin
d'annoncer qu'elle prépare je cite une
réponse c'est un coup dur qui a été
portée la nuit dernière en pl madrid a
la difficile normalisation du problème
basque espagnol le gall ce groupe
clandestin qui lutte à sa manière depuis
des années contre le terrorisme basque
le gall a revendiqué l'attentât qui a
tué un député nationaliste basque et qui
en a grièvement blessé un autre il
s'apprêtait pour la première fois à
siéger au parlement
bruno gex hier soir tout s'est passé
comme bien souvent au pays basque deux
hommes en cagoule surgissent dans ce
restaurant de madrid
des coups de feu tirés à bout portant et
deux hommes tombent
les voici quelques heures auparavant jo
sung ou rose à lui est mort et inaki
esnaola est grièvement blessé le plus
jeune était journaliste et avait
longuement vécu en france avant d'être
expulsé l'autre avocat avait permis de
renouer les premiers contacts entre le
gouvernement espagnol et les
indépendantistes de letea ces deux
hommes pensaient que le pays basque en
avait assez des bombes
élu député il avait eu le choix capital
avec leurs organisations herri batasuna
proche de letea de siéger au parlement
la peau chinois la prochaine législature
sera celle de la négociation avait dit
et snow la juste avant l'attentât
ce matin tous les députés espagnols se
sont levés pour observer une minute de
silence pour tous une même question qui
sont les responsables de l'attentât
des irréductibles basque du groupe armé
ou le groupe antiterroriste de
libération
le gall comme l'a dit un interlocuteur
au téléphone pour empêcher tout dialogue
avec le thé à et le gouvernement de
madrid
il y a cinq ans jour pour jour un autre
député basque senti boire était
assassiné le gall avait revendiqué
l'attentât
des milliers de basques avaient crié
vive le thé à militaires aujourd'hui à
bilbao pays basque espagnol climat
explosif et violents incidents sur place
michel mompontet philippe etcheverry
crime d'état contre yb batasuna
les photos des deux députés barrée de
noir l'heure n'était pas cet après midi
à la subtilité de la politique
politicienne mais à la colère
déclarations abruptes dans leader
déribat afina hier ce n'était pas un
crime contre la démocratie démocratie
contre le peuple basque derrière les
orateurs chema monde terreau le seul
député européen déry batasuna silencieux
visiblement choqué s'il n'avait été
retenu par une réunion à bruxelles ils
auraient dû
hier être à madrid avec ses compagnons
lors de l'attentât sur les murs de la
ville le nom de yushu maubeuge où ça et
sa photo sont partout un bouquet de
fleurs mais aussi des accusations
accusation qui a bilbao reviennent comme
un leitmotiv parti socialiste espagnol
et galgal le clean il profite au
gouvernement nous dit cette jeune femme
c'est un assassinat le gouvernement
s'est entièrement sa faute un autre pour
l'assassinât de centre l'avoir pour un
autre et les réactions extrêmes repli
dans la rue et qui ont disent long sur
la tension qui règne ici
mais ce soir à 22 heures avec l'arrivée
du corps de guéi maubeuge où ça dans le
centre de bilbao
la stupeur et le choc pourrait bien
laisser place à la colère et à la rage
ils étaient en effet nombreux ici à
croire en un espoir de paix pour le pays
basque
c'est optimiste on ce soir
singulièrement disparu et ce soir à
bayonne près de 200 personnes ont
manifesté dans le calme pour protester
contre l'attentât de madrid
la sphère du carrefour du développement
rebondi le directeur de la dst a été
entendu hier par le juge d'instruction
qui continuent de travailler sur le
dossier
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur en
l'occurrence charles pasqua qui en 86
aurait donné l'ordre à la dst donc au
contre-espionnage français de fabriquer
le vrai faux passeport d'yves jannier
hervé brusini l'histoire ne dit pas si
le préfet gérard le patron de la dst
souriait il hier lors de son entrevue
avec le juge jane en tout cas ici au
palais de justice le patron du contre
espionnage a révélé que c'est bien
charles pasqua ministre de l'intérieur
en 86 qui lui avait donné l'ordre de
fabriquer un vrai faux passeports
destinés à yves chalier ce document
établi au nom de navarro avait servi à
l'ancien chef de cabinet de l'ex
ministre de la coopération christian
nucci dans sa fuite au brésil
une affaire dans la sphère carrefour du
développement
pierre joxe l'actuel ministre
l'intérieur avait levé en partie le
secret défense pour que les
investigations de la justice se
poursuivent au grand damne de charles
pasqua
à présent c'est lui charles pasqua qui
risque de devoir répondre aux questions
du juge
il pourrait être inculpé d'utilisation
frauduleuse de documents administratifs
et l'on verrait alors l'ancien ministre
l'intérieur traduire haute cour de
justice
mais nous ne sommes pas là pour l'heure
charles pasqua reste silencieux
sénateurs il est protégé par une
immunité parlementaire
oui charles pasqua qui est en ce moment
au canada sont le team le président
mitterrand ira demain strasbourg il
exposera aux parlementaires européens
les conclusions de la rencontre des 12
samedi dernier à l'elysée et le
chancelier helmut kohl sera présent et
puis dans un mois du 20 au 22 décembre
monsieur mitterrand se rendra en
allemagne de l'est pour une visite
d'état à l'invitation des gones
craignent une visite qui aura lieu trois
jours après le congrès du parti
communiste est-allemand qui sera
critique pour l'évolution du régime
le numéro un est en mauvaise posture
même s'il s'efforce de présenter à
l'opinion
son visage le plus souriant et à
l'intérieur même du parti
la contestation est ouverte l'enquète à
berlin-est de philippe rouchon la ville
de dresde eux s'est mise au diapason de
celle de l'altitude 100 mille
manifestants ont demandé ici la
démission des gones ifans et siffler son
nom en passant devant le bâtiment de la
sécurité d'état
la police secrète nastasi egon krenz
peut-il survivre à la pression de la rue
qui reste toujours aussi forte
il est la cible numéro un des
manifestant es avec le chef du pc de la
région de berlin günter schabowski il
est le plus menacé
même au sein de son propre parti on lui
reproche d'avoir été l'homme de necker
contre qui un procès a même été demandé
krenz a toujours été présenté comme un
homme de transition née au sein d'un
parti qui se rajeunit
il est ressenti comme un membre de la
vielle garde on n'a jamais scandé le nom
de hans modrow le nouveau premier
ministre dans les manifestations il
n'est pas contesté au sein du parti
communiste et plus d'un disque l'avenir
lui appartient
même si les communistes dans une
élection ne ferait que 15% des voix
malgré les luttes internes au sein du
parti communiste est-allemand on
n'attend pas de bouleversement majeur
avant la fin du congrès du parti le sd
qui doit se tenir du 15 au 17 décembre
toutes les grandes décisions comme la
visite du chancelier kohl en allemagne
de l'est ont été remises
après cette date et le ministre ouest
allemands envoyés par helmut kohl pour
préparer cette visite poursuivi
aujourd'hui ses entretiens à berlin s'il
a rencontré les représentants de
l'église et de l'opposition pour la
première fois ce matin à berlin est des
artistes et autres tagueurs ont pu avec
l'autorisation de la police décorer le
mur de berlin
de leur côté à eux comme à l'ouest
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
réclamer ainsi que le mur soit préservée
mais comme oeuvres d'art
en roumanie la télévision la presse la
radio ne parle que d'une chose le
congrès du parti communiste roumain qui
glorifie depuis hier comme il se doit
son secrétaire général nicolas ceausescu
le congrès a lieu à huis clos
le centre de bucarest est pratiquement
en état de siège sur place jacques
merlino caire moscovitch le 14e congrès
du parti communiste roumain s'est
refermé sur lui-même les délégués et
siègent maintenant à huit clos et les
étrangers ne sont pas admis à suivre
leurs travaux il est vrai que l'enjeu
est de faible importance tout le monde
s'accorde à penser que nicolas ceaucescu
sera réélu triomphalement vendredi
prochain de fait on voit mal comment il
pourrait en être autrement
les rares opposants sont bouclés chez
eux et leur domicile gardé par la police
la ville est quadrillée par l'armée et
la milice et des barrages aux alentours
de la capitale refoulera pitoyablement
tout véhicule venant de province
quant aux frontières on sait que sont
durement fermé depuis la fin de la
semaine dernière la population vit cette
situation dans une résignation fort
c'est sa seule possibilité d'expression
et de marquer son indifférence devant la
multitude des portraits de nicolae
ceaucescu sur tous les murs de la ville
les roumains sont beaucoup plus
préoccupés par les difficultés de la vie
quotidienne que par un congrès sans
surprise les boutiques sont toujours
aussi mal approvisionné les files
d'attentes toujours aussi longue
alors que l'on s'apprête à inaugurer
officiellement le nouveau centre ville
d'une démesure impressionnante
ici tous les vieux quartiers ont été
rasés et une avenue de quatre kilomètres
de long débouche sur un palet monumental
dédiée à celui que l'on appelle le génie
des carpates
mais cette population contrainte au
silence c'est ce qui se passe à
l'étranger sur tous les toits des
antennes bricoler permettent de recevoir
la télévision
plus gare soviétique et hongroise c'est
par elle désormais qu'arrive
informations et espoir de changement à
moscou nouvelle victoire de michael
gorbatchev sur les conservateurs du
parti avec le limogeage du chef du pc de
moscou et son remplacement par un adepte
de la pérestroïka il n'était pas
d'accord et ils ne le sont toujours pas
le premier ministre israélien itzhak
shamir a été reçu aujourd'hui à l'élysée
par le président mitterrand qui a
insisté sur la nécessité de trouver une
solution au problème palestinien
monsieur shamir a tenté sans succès de
convaincre son hôte de la logique de la
politique israélienne
dans quelques jours ce sera le deuxième
anniversaire de l'intifada le
soulèvement palestinien dans les
territoires occupés
bernard benyamin qui a rencontré tout à
l'heure le premier ministre israélien
lui a demandé s'il entrevoyait une
solution au conflit
moi je ne cherche pas une solution
l'habitude fade
je cherche une solution au conflit
parce que l'intifada est l expression
des ces conflits qui existe depuis
beaucoup d'années même avoir le
tablissements de l'autre et à ondes les
peuples du sahel et les mandats elle
nous pensons que nous pouvons vaincre
dans chaque confrontation avec les
arabes mais il s'agit pas d'avoir dû
victoire il s'agit d'arriver à la coupe
et une dernière question est sur le pont
aux ministres elle concerne les
événements en europe de l'est
quel est votre sentiment au vu de cette
transformation du monde ou alors je suis
très émue pour ça et je suis très
heureux de voir ce changement
révolutionnaire et sont arrivés en
europe delhaize surtout c'est une
révolution sans violence
elle savait dire qu il
ça sent bolis une victoire à metz dans
l'esprit de la liberté de la démocratie
mais est elle a quelque chose dans tout
ça qui m'attriste
chez les fai qui tous à en avoir un
c'est même un signe de ses mouvements
dans notre région dans les proches rien
révolution médiatique aujourd'hui dans
la vie parlementaire britannique
les caméras de la télévision vont
désormais retransmettre les débats des
communes en font signer il aura fallu 25
ans de polémiques avant que les
britanniques retransmet à la télévision
c'est l'image des débats parlementaires
de la chambre des communes
jusqu'à présent seul le saut était
retransmis désormais un système
sophistiqué de caméras télécommandées
filmera les députés en évitant autant
possible ceux qui dorment mangent ils se
disputent ce système est mis à l'essai
pour six mois fin de l'impasse politique
en grèce avec la signature d'un accord
de gouvernement entre les trois
principaux partis conservateurs
socialistes et communistes
le gouvernement dirigé par xénon france
de l'eau tu as ancien gouverneur de la
banque de grèce devra mener le pays
jusqu'en avril prochain
enlèvement de 1% des quotas laitiers
décision des ministres de l'agriculture
des douze aujourd'hui à bruxelles depuis
leur création en 84 c'est la première
fois que ces quotas augmente
en contrepartie les producteurs qui les
dépasse enverront leurs finalités
augmenté
rudolph noureev n'est plus directeur de
la danse de l'opéra de paris pierre
bergé a mis aujourd'hui fin à ses
fonctions
mes frais pour lui un poste de premier
chorégraphe noureev avait été nommé 180
points
et
à la bourse de paris baisse de 0 51% de
l'indicateur de référence
le dollar s'échange à la baisse à 6
francs 19 46
le finlandais juha kankkunen sur toyota
toujours en tête du rallye de grande
bretagne
en revanche son coéquipier ari vatanen
part en tonneaux aujourd'hui et perd la
cinquième place au profit de timo
salonen tonneau réussi de nuremberg à
nuremberg tout de suite après le journal
vous avez rendez vous ce soir sur
antenne 2 avec un formidable document
signé philippe meyer et frédéric rossif
des faits des images qu'il faut gravé
dans notre mémoire collective des images
du nazisme et dans le premier épisode
que vous suivrez ce soir irrésistible
ascension du pouvoir et les rien jusqu'à
ce qu'ils ne s'enlisent dans la guerre
une orgie petit plus rimbert 1935 le
prion vie claire et du nazisme nuremberg
1945 dix ans plus tard prostré anéanti
vaincu les hauts dignitaires du
troisième reich sont jugés et condamnés
entre ces deux images une guerre
mondiale meurtrière est l'expression de
la barbarie la découverte des camps
d'extermination
le bilan du nazisme dressé dans un film
document de nuremberg à nuremberg
un film dont les auteurs n'ont pas voulu
faire une énième production sur la
deuxième guerre mondiale
c'est un film sur le nazisme
c'est un film sur commande nazisme a été
possible qui sont les gens qui l'ont
rendu possible
qui sont les gens qui par aveuglement ne
l'ont pas combattu qui sont les gens qui
ont été complices et qui sont les gens
qui ont des faits finalement ce nazi un
film sur le nazisme ou destinées aussi
et surtout à la mémoire collective pour
que personne n'oublie jamais on a fait
cette fine pourrait donner actuellement
un fragment de même moins disparu semé
spring and pour redonner du nazi
pourrait donner cette histoire qui est
la nôtre
mchale accélération historique portent à
l'oubli
conçu comme un fragment de la mémoire
collective de nuremberg à nuremberg est
donc un film témoin témoin à charge
contre un passé dans toutes les cendres
ne sont peut-être pas tout à fait éteint
de nuremberg à nuremberg donc ce soir et
demain soir aux dossiers de l'écran le
cinéma espagnol à l'honneur à paris ces
jours ci avec un festival où l'on peut
voir une douzaine de films inédits
il témoigne de la vitalité du cinéma
ibérique
nicole cornu langlois au rythme des
chansons à la mode et des caricatures de
danses folkloriques
voici les choses de l'amour c'est l'un
des films de ce festival reflets de
l'espagne de l'après franquisme les
tabous ont volé en éclats c'est
l'ivresse des émotions délibérations des
fantasmes un festival qui rassemble les
enfants du duel et les cousins de
berlanga où almodovar cinéma espagnol
y'a jamais un dominateur
comment vous savez l'histoire nous
sommes ça il est comme le mausolée à la
menthe a calé au sol est nouveau et
notre film sont comblés beaujolais un
petit peu moins sucré avait beaucoup de
soufre d'amour des aventures des atouts
échantillons qui ont pré sainte aussi du
paroxysme et de l'extravagance comme au
temps de l'âge d'or
ainsi dans les cauchemars d'un journal
d'une saison où pedro leon fernando rey
pratiquer l'euthanasie douce dans
aventis la belle victoria abril enceinte
incarne la femme rêvée dans un monde
obscènes et grotesque où les enfants
inventent des jeux cruels qu'elle
alignait surréalisme toujours présent
c'est un cinéma qui a perdu la peur qui
luttent pour garder son identité mais en
même temps je cherche un marché européen
comme l'a déjà réussi un réalisateur
international carlos saura dont le
dernier film la nuit obscure est un
hommage à la créativité douloureuse de
saint jean de la croix
espagne la dame âgée banda los le masque
sur trois hypothèses glastonbury un
thème universel du mysticisme à
l'instant les résultats du tiercé du
quinté plus qui se courait en nocturne à
vincennes à l'arrivée le 5 le 19 le 12
le 9 et le 6 se répète le 5 le 19 le 12
le 9 et le 6 mai je ne connais pas
encore les rapports
voilà dans un instant laurent cabrol
pour la météo demain et non ce soir 22h
henri sannier pour notre dernière
édition demain matin invité des 4
vérités de france au conflit à 7h45
pierre lefranc le vice-président de
l'institut charles de gaulle à
l'occasion du 99ème anniversaire de la
naissance du général très bonne soirée
sur enter deux admirateurs